the chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett he's with us at the table
morning everybody well we had Biden we
had Warren we had Sanders on the same
stage for the first time yep
how did they fare so after debates three
times now the Biden campaign has never
made the case that he was the clear
winner of any of the three debates what
does this tell us he's playing a game of
survival doesn't need to win just
survive
maybe pass/fail is the way to think
about this in an academic sense and what
do we see about Warren and Sanders the
non-aggression pact we've talked about
here before continues why keep the
progressive lane wide it's not time yet
start going at each other at kalos 30
you can't last forever
right but those three more or less
coexisted at the top other thing to
observe the other is cory booker Amy
Klobuchar
pee poo to judge come on double Harris
all wanted to be sunny unifying
alternatives unity why do they want to
do that strategically because they know
someday the biden sanders warren clash
is coming they want to be coming right
in behind that to position themselves
for that clash to come what did you
geographically amy klobuchar because
she's from Minnesota near Iowa is it
best positioned to have a moment as that
alternative once that clash comes what
did you make of Castro's attack on
unbuttoned that as I pointed out so the
reaction in the room suggested something
that is already on the minds of the
audience there and in the Democratic
Party writ large who is Joe Biden the
former vice president up to this that
gas was a reflection of that tension did
you will then Castro helped himself
probably not because again the sunny
alternative is the place to be not the
pound on Joe Biden as the age it may
have been viewed as a low blow limited
Democratic yeah you have to figure out a
way there are other ways to do that you
might have misremembered I don't want to
exactly do things I don't want to assume
the worst he assumed the worst yeah
about the former vice president that
puts them in an awkward position got to
figure out a way to attack it seems in
these situations without making their
personal attack and many people took
that as a personal as you said Anthony
low blow
what about better O'Rourke's comment
about guns where he said hell yes we're
gonna take your ak-47s great reaction in
the room how do you think it played
additionally problematic legislatively
almost impossible but one thing I think
you can fairly say about better O'Rourke
he's been transformed by a horrible
event during this campaign in real time
all of that I was born to this Vanity
Fair wanderlust about his campaign
that's gone yes he's the candidate of
conviction on a real time issue and he
looked much more serious and focused
about what this is for him not saying
he's gonna win or even get in the top
tier but he looks and sounds like a
fundamentally different candidate
transformed by a horror in his hometown
when you talk about authenticity as
terrible as it was to achieve it he's
much closer to it that he's been before
all right major Garrett Thank You major